[Music]
Joseph Smith claimed Divine Visions
peered into a hat to uncovered secrets
and even said a golden plaque was
delivered to him by a Heavenly messenger
and he says he looked through these
stones at the Egyptian Engravings on
these Golden Plates and they would turn
into English but could these rituals and
mysterious objects hint at something
deeper something hidden what was the
real inspiration behind these practices
and why do they seem so eily familiar to
other secretive traditions stay with us
as we uncover the Intriguing truth
behind Joseph Smith's extraordinary
claims so one of the things that's
interesting is Mormons and Masons often
get connected because Joseph Smith was a
Mason um he became a first-degree Mason
and he says WR in his journal the number
of Masons grew dramatically in the
Navajo Lodge eventually grown into some
1500 members only 2,72 in the rest of
the United States so at one point and
this is a this is a book written by
Mormons that you're seeing on the screen
there um this is them trying to set the
record straight and I'm quoting right
from the book um in a footnote so
there's a lot of crossover with
Freemasonry and Mormonism the idea of a
lodge um and Temple practices a lot of
that seems to have been derived or has
similar links or inspired or however you
want to put that from Joseph Smith's
Masonic connection interesting so um
that one's just interesting um you can
see here it says in t Tuesday March 15
it says I officiated as Grand chaplain
at the installation of the Nabu Lodge of
Freemasons at the Grove near the temple
in the evening I received the first
degree um and so if you go on so that
was Tuesday March 15th now Wednesday
March 16th next day I was at the Masonic
lodge and Rose to the sublime degree so
he jumped more levels and degrees than
anybody I've ever read about so what
what degree did he make it to uh that's
debatable 30 second I mean you you
pretty much know what's going on the
curtains there yeah so he jumped very
very rapidly that's interesting um which
is kind of interesting and even so this
is a quote from Jonathan Blanchard he
was a former 33rd degree Freemason of
the Scottish Rite he gives an
interesting Insight he says it's legend
in the 14th degree initiation says that
the real name of God was lost till it
was found by the Masons engraved on
three cornered gold plates in the ruins
of Enoch who's a prophet The Book of
Mormon whether the Mormon Joseph Smith
who was a Mason took this story of gold
plates from this on or invented a like
Legend of his own the two are similar in
origin nature and effect they both
utterly destroy Christianity while
pretending to favor and expand it that's
interesting so this was from Aon he says
you know when I looked at when he looked
at Mormonism he's like wow what Joseph
SMI did it sounds just like what I
learned in masonry so he's kind of
elating like man Mormonism must be real
because it it kind of lines up with what
yeah so there's a similar story there so
you know the reason why people say
they're tied and there's confusion um it
is because there are quotes out there
like this that show that he did have
those links wow now um is this the same
um Book of Enoch like The Book of Enoch
that I see some people quoting out of
apocryphal apocryphal book does that
come from
Mormonism uh there no where's this book
of
like like do the do Mormons recognize
the Book of Enoch as Canon so sud figura
is a interesting topic um and the
Apocrypha so pigura that means they had
a false name on it so Enoch they don't
believe the Book of Enoch was really
written by Enoch because it didn't
appear to way later and so there's Pig
Brooks so it's interesting because
Joseph Smith had to correct the Bible
but when he was asked about the S of
figur he said there's nothing wrong with
it wow oh and so he didn't correct it so
it's kind of interesting and that's
right in um Doctrine and Covenant and
what is the that I've never heard of
that pseud fig pseud fig it's pseudo
like uh a false uh figur signature Sal
false signature that's where it comes
from so there's a number of books out
there that are pigura meaning someone
wrote it as though they were someone
else pretending to give it credibility
yeah interesting so could it be s
[Music]
a